now I know it's not my fault it's my
responsibility to end it I'm gonna kill
him
hey youtubers it's Charlie so arrow
trailer for episode 10 teasing that we
might see someone in the grave I really
think it's a big mr. egg but let's break
it down if there was any confusion
arrows coming back on the 20th the flash
is coming back on the 19th the you know
the day before that because it's Tuesday
Wednesday and then Thursday is Episode
one of legends of tomorrow but let's
talk about what happened to Felicity at
the end of episode 9 the takeaway from
the trailer is is that someone still
ends up in the grave and Felicity is
getting wheeled into critical care so if
you were to take it literally you're
like oh my god she's gonna be one in the
grave
Oliver is going to finish this because
she's dead and he's pissed off here's
why I think that's bullcrap because I
think the trailer is just meant to get
you hyped up and they're just using some
mr. X first reason why the flash-forward
at the beginning of the season was six
months arrow moves in real time and
unless they purposefully change that
just to mislead us that grave scene is
still from the flash four to six months
which would put it at the end of the
season you know like episode 22 episode
23 you know sometime in the last couple
weeks of the season so we're still a
long ways away from that so I'm not
expecting anyone from this episode
episode 9 to end up in the grave at best
I think what they're doing is a version
of what they did with Oliver last season
like they made you think that he was
dead and he was just out of commission
for a couple of weeks so what might end
up happening is his Felicity will just
get sidelined for a couple of weeks and
team arrow will have to go on without
her skills but the thing is number two
big reason to bringing her father on the
TV show they've already said that he's
gonna be the calculator it's Tommy
Montez I think I'm pronouncing his last
name right he's the dad from Everwood
like the really mean dad from Everwood
that is gonna be the episode that they
bring colton back in so Roy's gonna be
in that episode the calculator will be
controlling Roy making him commit crimes
you know blackmailing him into
committing crimes for him team arrow is
gonna have to rescue him
so what better than to have an episode
where Felicity gets to defeat her father
you know big daddy issues episode there
is no one on arrow that does not have
daddy issues and wouldn't like one more
chance to tell their fathers off so I
think she'll be back by the time that
episode happens I don't know exactly
when that episode is dropping or you
know what the number is ability
somewhere in the middle of the back half
of the season number three big reason
there's no one else on team arrow that
does her job that has her skills sure we
have mr. terrific but he's more of a
background player he's more of like the
inventor character
he's not like the scientist that mans
the computers if anything he would be
out in the field with team arrow bronze
metal decathlete you don't sideline
someone like that when they have the
physical skills to go out and punch
people in the face so for all intents
and purposes felicity is the Oracle of
team arrow I mean they're not gonna call
her Oracle because I think Barbara
Gordon is supposed to be on the Teen
Titans TV show which is still like way
deep in development there's there's
really no news about that TV show
everyone that's wondering about it but
Felicity is the hacker who manages the
flow of information using their crazy
Cisco designed computer networks she is
also the CEO of Palmer tech so she is
where they get all of their money for
their toys from and she's already said
that she does report to a board so like
she still has to clear purchases with
them like she still has to explain where
millions of dollars are going now until
Oliver gets his money back it's still
gonna be Palmer tech and he's going to
be mayor so he just he does not have
time to be in the corporate boardroom
and manage that company so there's
really like two big functions that
Felicity has right now that can't be
replaced immediately with other
characters inside team arrow so I really
like what the writers did with her
character in episode 9 where it's like
oh you know everything's wonderful
and they pull the rug out from under him
with this season two moment team arrow
has to scramble so they're gonna spend
the next couple of episodes trying to
deal without felicity so the big focus
is learning about what damian darhk-- is
doing with this mysterious cornfield
like this biological agent he's trying
to disseminate and keep Oliver from
killing everybody he runs into but that
still doesn't address who ends up in
that grave and I really don't think that
we're meant to know that yet it's it's
like the zoom identity thing on the
flash you're supposed to get a little
bit of clues they keep teasing the
reveal that it might be someone that we
know but we probably won't find out -
like the last couple of episodes the
reason I keep thinking that it's like
Diggle or Quentin but we'll start with
Quentin because right now he's on the
chopping block it's just because his
role isn't quite as critical as the
other team arrow members anybody could
rise up and be police chief Quentin
isn't even really using the police
department to help team arrow he's just
trying to not hurt them but inside the
group he's really kind of like the old
adviser and honestly like how much
advice has Quentin given team arrow that
they haven't gotten from other
characters that has been better
Quentin is really just like a public
figure in Star City in a position of
authority that tries to help team arrow
and
Oliver becomes mayor he will be that
person himself so Oliver in a way is
kind of replacing Quentin's role in the
narrative tomorrow largely a shadow
organization operating at night
defeating villains needs someone during
the day you know the daylight to help
them and that's who Oliver Queen is
becoming and also you have to think
about Quentin aligning himself with
damian darhk-- there's gonna be a big
price to pay for doing that like he made
probably one of the worst decisions ever
even though it was the best one at the
time so that's gonna bite him in the ass
and he went on to say that there is
nothing that he would not do for his
daughters including lay down his life so
think about Quentin is doing the same
types of things that Moira queen did
like Maura Queen was happy to die for
her children even though it was a big
WTF you know everyone was screaming
crying Oliver went crazy so I think the
same types of things are happening with
the Quentin character and Diggle you
know you could give any number of
reasons why Diggle would be a really bad
person to kill on arrow
but if anything's gonna bite him in the
ass like if they want to go really dark
like do something really really terrible
they would have his brother kill Diggle
but I think an even bigger WTF would be
if Diggle himself had to kill his
brother
you know vice versa so even though arrow
doesn't have like quite the big you know
spectacle but special powers that the
flash does they have actually like a
number of big WTF story points that they
can mine if they want to go really dark
and arrow really is like the darker TV
show flash is meant to be a little bit
lighter a little bit sillier arrow is
like the dark crime drama like The Wire
done with superheroes if any of you ever
watch the HBO series so let me know in
the comments below big question for you
guys
do you think that the grave scene in
this trailer for episode 10 is a
complete misdirect I just feel like the
matically where they're taking all these
characters you know little clues or
telling us that Felicity will come back
but somebody's definitely ending up in
that grave in the really interesting
thing like when you're thinking about
what they're doing with the characters
each season the writers don't always
know exactly what's going to be
happening like every single episode
sometimes they will change their plans
in the back half the flash is the best
example that the Eddie Thawne character
like the way he ended they didn't intend
for that to happen originally they had
other plans for the character so between
the start of the season and the end of
the season a lot of their plans for
characters can change but what's gonna
happen is is there is a new Deadpool
trailer that's coming really soon
there's also supposed to be one on
Christmas Day like a Deadpool trail on
Christmas Day but there's like three
different Deadpool trailers one of them
is gonna be 3d in theaters
there's a bunch of trailers that they're
dropping with Star Wars next week in
theaters just be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'll do videos for
everything as soon as stuff drops so it
is gonna be a really awesome really busy
week congratulations to the winner of
this week's reverse flash ring giveaway
Elliott Sutton be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info I wasn't
super excited about the independence
trailer so I'm not planning on doing a
video for that I'll probably do Batman V
Superman next or maybe Game of Thrones
or Walking Dead or something like that
just let me know in the comments what
you know what you guys want in terms of
bonus videos next week there's gonna be
a whole bunch of trailers so they'll at
least be that way cos wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
flash episode 10 trailer that's gonna be
mirror master so so much fun and you can
click here for the Star Wars video I
posted last night thank you so much for
watching everybody let's have up I'll
see you guys tonight